ah les plages de miami
juste avant l'arrivée du troisième
enfant le moment idéal pour eloïse
pierre-luc pour s'offrir un voyage en
floride pour ne pas se casser la tête
ils font affaire avec une agence de
voyages mais le médecin d'eloïse leur
apprend que le virus sica est rendu en
floride et leur déconseille fortement
d'y aller à cause des risques pour le
bébé
héloïse et pierre-luc demande une
annulation et un remboursement à leur
agence l'agent est piqué au vif
il répond aux questions nous n'avions
pas à vous le dire tout le monde sait ça
eh bien c'est faux un agent de voyages
qui sert une cliente enceinte doit
savoir où se trouvent les cas
d'infection par le virus 6-4 et l'en
informer héloïse et pierre-luc sont donc
en droit d'exiger un remboursement le
fin mot de l'histoire
un voyageur ne peut pas tout savoir
c'est pourquoi l' agence doit d'ivoire